and I um show a new
cultured anime had been released yes and
it was just [__] Red Riding Hood
being smashed by the wolf
and I think that was the whole premise
but the wolf was like had like rizz
I like watched six I was like I wanted
to see how how possibly they could sell
this Grandma what big risk you have it
was like no no it was like the wolf was
like it was like trying to like Smooth
talk it was really [__] weird and uh
let me uh the second episode was like
it's like even weirder let me see what
it was real quick
okay oh my God yeah just I don't know I
feel like the I think like the biggest
problem with a lot of horror anime is
just like a lot of them just do not
adapt yeah into animation like they're
fine in manga format yeah or you know
even light novel format like game format
but just something about anime it just
makes it fantastic it's less scary I
don't know why yeah do you know what I
love like when when there's when you're
just watching an anime that's not a
horror anime but there'll just be this
really scary episode in it kind of what
is it oh my [__] let's see I thought
it was like when you said the wolf right
I thought you meant like someone dressed
up straight up a wolf and the second
episode was like Alice in Wonderland
being smashed by like I think like a Mad
Hatter or something bro the hentai this
year has been straight ass yeah you've
got no good [__] yeah I have not
watching other than the hentai episode
Joey like like anime uh hentai is going
down the same route Joey just stop
watching yeah
[Music]
no because like that shit's invading
anime now as well because like I you
know I did it not uh [__] like I did
I did a video recently on like an anime
and it is an anime it's called Uh my uh
my life is uniquized dog
I've heard about this one and it's it's
a show where a guy for some reason wakes
up and uh he wakes up as a dog and his
high school Crush picks him up and
adopts the dog yeah and you know it's
it's an edgy anime so I initially I
thought he was just I've I've seen this
in the uh before like POV you were the
girl and she's exercising or something
like that yeah so I thought it would
just be I thought that him being
reincarnated as a dog would be just like
a reason just for some very interesting
let's say anime Cameron it's a POV anime
it's kind of a peony
um and then you watch episode one and
then you realize oh like this girl
inukai this girl she likes the dog like
she really likes the dog no no God no
wow and it's it's not even like it's not
even like a uh reincarnated dog it's not
a it's it's not a person wearing a dog
[Music]
hasn't gone that far yet but it's it's a
harem it's happening
how many what it's like three or four
and Counting right now
it's it's like I I watched it and I'm
like this that's it yeah you know that's
not my line you know that is terrifying
though that is this is my line right now
I thought it's it's Red Riding had been
grailed by the wolf was bad it's
terrifying because this is not the first
time we've had a concept like this in
anime because a while back we had dog
and scissors yeah this one goes this one
tastes like but this just seems like if
dog and scissors went down the entire
out all right I'm gonna say one thing
that happens in the manga yeah
breastfeeding
hey y'all who and who who is
breastfeeding who the dog the dog is
being breastfed
by one of the girls and
no no no no no hold on
now explain to me hang on an hour a
minute now I gotta ask why in the [__]
would you breastfeed a dog we're a long
way from Texas we are a long way from
Texas for a reason would you as a human
being have is a need to breastfeed a dog
there's no world oh hey good to know at
least the anime has a dolphin just make
porn
I kind of wish they did
I can't believe this is an anime yeah I
I I I saw this screenshots of it I'm
like oh sick new hentai just came out
yeah and then people are like oh no it's
being streamed I'm like wait where you
thought well you said you thought it was
a sick enter no I was like
and I was like all right people are
talking about this hentai sure and then
everyone was like no you can watch it on
streaming sites I'm like yeah it's crazy
how you literally just say hentai and
everyone like absolutely just is
immediately cool with like gigaf
because at this point it's like it's not
a surprise yeah at this point we've had
no idea I'm done
like I'm I'm I feel like okay I feel
like there should be a line between
anime and hentai right because anime
it'd get aired it's it's getting aired
on TV there are like there are some
barriers but there aren't as aren't as
many barriers as some of the stuff you
see in hentai you know hentai you have
to go out your way to find hentai and
also because of that there's you know
it's it's kind of like mixing porn with
just normal media okay it's of course
there's a place for that stuff yes I
feel and by
by reducing and kind of like getting rid
of the barrier as much as anime has
recently it's getting harder and harder
to distinguish the [__] up things that
is happening in anime versus what's
happening in Hensel I mean I was
thinking that when issues local
reviewers came out yeah I was like bro
this is how is this being aired like I'm
like the the manga is fine because it's
you know it's published by like uh a
publication that's more oriented towards
like yeah manga right so it's like
whatever it fits in there who cares
right but then when they started really
when they started airing it and I was
like oh they they're keeping everything
in yeah oh [__] okay why is this not on
the inside website that's a bold move
yeah I I respect it I respect it at the
time I respected it but now I see
unikai's dog I'm like this is the exact
moment where humanity went on the wrong
path okay if this led to unikai's dog we
have gone down the wrong timeline right
now yes if ishizaka reviews didn't pop
off oh this never would have happened if
harambe never gone I'm just saying it
right now none of this harambe would
have saved us none of this would have
happened if I didn't get shot like
straight up oh yeah
huh what is this airing right now it
just finished airing oh it's finished it
just finished it was airing in winter
season you know as soon as you know I
was fine with the degeneration what were
people saying on YouTube about this
thing we were fine with the degeneral I
was fun with the degenerative stuff and
to be fair I'm still fine with the
degenerate stuff you know but as soon as
we started touching our dogs
literally with inequalized dogs that's
why I was like okay anime has gone too
far now
what are the top comments to like an
anime recap of this is nah bro what is
this crying face
the fact that it's like POV as well is
just like even more unsettling because
yeah that means this was made with a
potential demographic in mind
there are a number of people regardless
of gender who looked at this and went
hell yeah this is my fantasy right here
dude now I can finally live my dream of
being recondidated into a dog getting
breastfed this is really tough for me as
a human being because I am very
anti-censorship and anything you want to
do at the same time I'm like you just
didn't have to make this you didn't have
to I don't know how we can not censor
you without without just without
figuring out a way how I can just get
you to not [__] like this I'm not
gonna ask you to delete the Tweet but it
should have stayed
I would never enforce being able to
delete your work yeah but how do I
delete it for you
how can I just delete this from the
internet and everyone's Consciousness
but this is like the the [__] tough
the sweating button thing like I I am
vehemently anti-censorship but like this
is like this pushes it where I'm like
dude something shouldn't be made like
this shouldn't be an anime this should
be on a hentai website like a soft like
in the in the vanilla category of like
yeah it's it's whatever it's some
[__] nice [__] happens yeah yeah
thanks for getting Yoshi lucky episode
three and four that's that's the thing
oh are we yeah [__] yeah and we're
getting more five and six it's been a
match two let's go
I do miss the high school for the dead
days though you know oh my God the order
I get a piece the older I get the more I
realize yeah that was a classic dude
it's a banger that was a classic show
man I owned that on Blu-ray did you
really I don't even have a Blu-ray
player
I collected anime Blu-rays just because
I liked like collecting the physical
media yeah yeah yeah I never had
anything to watch it on you know like
because I'm thinking back and I was just
like there is no other anime like High
School of the Dead no that just has so
much
care and attention being put into equal
parts of just action and just being
[__] horny normally it's like you
just are either it's a really really
[__] horny show and that's the only
reason you're watching it
I never remember the episode is this the
one made by the Death Note guy yeah yeah
yeah no no no no no no no it was
directed by the same guy that directed
the anime the author's dead yeah who who
for what high schools are dead oh oh
yeah
yeah but the same guy who directed High
School the dead direct to death note and
season one of Attack on Titan as well
all right yeah yeah yeah which is which
is why so this manage doesn't miss this
man doesn't miss coded the fact that he
could make High School of the Dead as
memorable as it is even though it's the
[__] dumbest plot line and it's just
there to be horny but yeah the action in
it just slaps so he's still a hood
classic oh man
that that [__] scene with the boob
Matrix he was ahead of his time that
seed is still etched into my mind to
this day it's like anytime I want to
feel like a teenager again I just pop on
that scene I'm like oh I'm gonna shoot a
rifle through a pair of flopping tits
while using another pair of tits as
Leverage
can't make that [__] up yeah so good I
do I remember how it ends no no do I
care also no imagine if we got the
director to Direct One Punch man again
oh my God yeah that would be incredible
am I am I crazy is why Marshall season
three coming out it's coming out it's
coming right yeah okay I'm not crazy I
didn't imagine that I believe the rumors
are that studio mapper have got the last
how how do they have everything I don't
know bro they're like Thanos right now
they're like another one for the
collection another classic Adam yeah
same yeah I don't I don't know how
they're collecting everything I think
they're taking a lot of like chainsaw
man was like a big risk for them because
they actually like funded it themselves
so that's why they have a risk sorry
that was not a risk I mean it was it's
something new that most anime Studios
haven't done they haven't funded their
own anime [__] big brain yeah and of
course it's kind of like It's gotta have
paid off but that's kind of the reason
why chainsaw man has had was able to
have like I guess like 12 different
endings and the insane [__] yeah that
was insane that was such Overkill but
man I was living for yeah